La laideur envahissante
de notre environnement quotidien en Amérique
c'est l'entropie rendue visible.
On ne peut surestimer la quantité de désespoir
que nous créons avec de tels espaces.
Et avant tout, j'aimerais vous convaincre que nous devons faire mieux
si nous devons poursuivre le projet de civilisation de l'Amérique.
Au fait, ceci n'arrange pas les choses.
Ceci n'égaye pas notre journée
Il y a plusieurs façons de décrire ceci
vous savez, j'appelle ça "le bidonville national de l'automobile"
Vous pouvez appeler cela urbanisation tentaculaire.
Je pense qu'on peut appeler ça
la pire allocation des ressources dans l'histoire de l'Humanité.
Vous pouvez appeler cela un brouillamini de technorrhée externe.
Et c'est un énorme problème pour nous.
Evidemment - le problème frappant pour nous avec cette situation
est qu'il s'agit là d'espaces dont nous ne nous préoccupons pas.
Nous en parlerons un peu plus.
Le sens du lieu.
La capacité à pouvoir créer des lieux qui ont un sens, des lieux de qualité et de caractère
dépend entièrement de notre capacité à définir l'espace et le bâti
et à employer des vocabulaires, des grammaires
des syntaxes, des rythmes et les motifs de l'architecture
afin d'enseigner qui nous sommes.
L'espace public en Amérique a deux rôles:
C'est le lieu où réside notre civilisation et notre vie civique
et c'est la manifestation physique du bien commun.
Et lorsque l'on dégrade l'espace public,
on dégrade automatiquement la qualité de la vie civique
et le caractère des différentes facettes de la vie publique et de la communauté
L'espace public se manifeste essentiellement sous la forme de la rue, en Amérique
parce que nous n'avons pas les parvis millénaires
ni les places du marché propres aux cultures plus anciennes.
Et notre capacité à définir l'espace et à créer des lieux qui méritent que l'on s'en préoccupe
tout provient d'une discipline culturelle qu'on appelle la culture du design civique
C'est un ensemble qui combine le savoir, la méthodologie, le savoir-faire et le sens du principe
que nous avons jeté à la poubelle après la Seconde Guerre Mondiale
et nous avons décidé que nous n'en avions pas besoin; que nous n'allions pas nous en servir
Par conséquent, nous voyons le résultat partout autour de nous
L'espace public doit non seulement nous indiquer où nous sommes géographiquement
mais il doit aussi nous indiquer où nous sommes dans notre culture
D'où nous venons, quel type de gens nous sommes, et il doit --
-- en faisant cela, il doit nous donner une indication d'où nous allons
afin que nous puissions vivre dans un présent doté d'espoir
L'énorme --
L'énorme catastrophe qui résulte des lieux que nous avons construits
de l'environnement humain que nous avons créé depuis 50 ans,
est liée au fait qu'ils nous ont privés de notre capacité à vivre dans un présent doté d'espoir
Les lieux dans lesquels nous vivons sont typiquement comme ça
Vous voyez ici la ceinture d'astéroïdes d'architecture-poubelle située à trois kilomètres au nord de ma ville.
Et n'oubliez pas, pour créer un lieu de caractère et de qualité,
vous devez pouvoir définir l'espace.
Comment a-t-on accompli cela ici?
Si vous vous placez devant le Wall-Mart ici
et essayez de regarder vers le magasin Target par là
vous ne le voyez pas à cause de la courbure de la Terre (Rires)
C'est la nature qui vous dit, à sa façon, que vous définissez mal l'espace.
Par conséquent, ce seront des lieux où personne ne voudra être
Ce sont des lieux qui nous laissent indifférents
Il y a, vous savez, environ 38000 lieux
qui nous laissent indifférents aux Etats-Unis aujourd'hui.
Lorsque nous en aurons suffisamment, notre nation nous laissera indifférents
Et j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez à cela lorsque vous pensez
aux jeunes hommes et femmes qui sont à des endroits comme l'Irak,
à verser leur sang sur le sable.
Et posez-vous la question: quelle est leur dernière pensée de leur pays natal?
J'espère que ce n'est pas la courbe entre le Chuck E. Cheese et le magasin Target!
Parce que cela ne suffit pas à justifier le sang versé par ces Américains. (Applaudissements)
Nous méritons de meilleurs lieux dans ce pays.
L'espace public. Voici un bel espace public.
C'est un lieu auquel on s'attache. Il est bien défini.
Cela s'apparente clairement à une pièce publique extérieure.
Il y a là quelque chose de terriblement important -
Il est doté de ce qu'on appelle une membrane périphérique active et perméable.
C'est une manière un peu compliquée de dire qu'il y a des boutiques, des bistrots et des lieux de destination--
-- on y entre, on en sort. C'est perméable.
La bière entre et sort, les serveuses entrent et sortent,
et cela active le centre du lieu et en fait un lieu où l'on a envie de se retrouver.
Vous savez, dans ces lieux, dans d'autres cultures,
les gens y vont simplement parce qu'ils aiment ça
Ils n'ont pas besoin d'organiser une foire artisanale pour faire venir les gens (Rires)
Vous savez, on n'a pas besoin d'un festival Kwanzaa
Les gens viennent parce que c'est un lieu agréable.
Mais c'est comme ça que l'on fait les choses aux Etats-Unis
Probablement l'échec le plus frappant en matière d'espace public aux Etats-Unis
conçu par les architectes de pointe du moment, Harry Cobb et I.M. Pei:
La place de l'Hôtel de Ville de Boston.
Un espace public si déprimant que même les ivrognes n'y vont pas (Rires)
Et nous ne pouvons y remédier car I.M. Pei est encore vivant,
et chaque année Harvard et le M.I.T. organisent un comité pour y remédier.
Et chaque année, c'est un échec, car ils ne veulent pas vexer I.M. Pei.
Voici l'autre façade du bâtiment.
C'était le gagnant d'un prix international de design il me semble, en 1966, environ.
Ce n'était ni Pei, ni Cobb, une autre firme l'a conçu.
Mais il n'y a pas suffisamment de Prozac dans le monde pour que les gens se sentent bien dans cette rue.
Voici l'arrière de l'Hôtel de Ville de Boston,
l'édifice public le plus important, vous savez, le plus symbolique à Albany -- pardon -- à Boston
Et quel est le message qui nous parvient --
Quels sont les vocabulaires et les grammaires qui se dégagent de cet édifice
et que dit l'édifice sur qui nous sommes?
Ce serait un plus bel édifice si on y peignait des portraits en mosaïque
de Josef Staline, Pol Pot, Saddam Hussein,
et de tous les grands despotes du 20ème siècle sur le côté de l'édifice,
parce que là au moins, on pourrait penser que l'édifice communique vraiment avec nous
Vous voyez, il s'agit là d'un édifice despotique;
il veut qu'on se sente comme des termites. (Rires)
Le voici à plus petite échelle.
L'arrière du centre civique de ma ville, Saratoga Springs, New York.
A propos, lorsque j'ai montré cette photo à un groupe de Kiwanians de ma ville,
ils se sont tous levés avec indignation, abandonnant leur poulet à la crème. (Rires)
Et se sont exclamés,
"Il pleuvait ce jour là lorsque vous avez pris la photo!"
Parce que pour eux c'était un problème météorologique. (Rires)
Vouz voyez, cet édifice est conçu comme un lecteur DVD. (Rires)
Sortie audio, alimentation --
Et regardez, vous savez que ces commandes sont importantes pour les grands cabinets d'architectes, non?
Vous voyez, nous employons des grandes boîtes pour concevoir tout ça.
Vous voyez ici exactement ce qui s'est passé à trois heures du matin en réunion design.
Huit heures avant la date limite,
quatre architectes essayent de soumettre une proposition dans les délais.
Et ils sont assis à la longue table de la salle de conférence
avec tous leurs dessins, et croquis en situation,
avec des emballages de plats chinois à emporter sur la table, et --
Quelle pouvait bien être leur conversation à ce moment là? (Rires)
Parce qu'il faut savoir quel était leur dernier mot, la dernière phrase de la réunion.
C'était: "On s'en fout" (Rires) (Applaudissements)
C'est bien ça -- le message qui provient de cette forme d'architecture.
Le message dit: On s'en fout! On s'en fout!
Alors j'y suis retourné le plus beau jour de l'année, juste pour --
juste pour vérifier.
Et en fait, même lui n'ira pas car --
ce n'est pas assez intéressant pour ses clients,
vous savez, les voleurs, les agresseurs.
Ce n'est pas civiquement assez riche pour qu'ils y aillent.
OK.
Le motif de la rue principale aux Etats-Unis --
en fait, ce schéma de centre ville est assez universel, partout dans le monde.
Ce n'est pas si compliqué --
les immeubles de plus d'un étage sont construits près du trottoir,
afin que les gens -- vous savez, toutes sortes de gens, puissent accéder à l'immeuble.
D'autres activités peuvent occuper l'étage supérieur,
vous savez, des appartements, des bureaux, etc.
Vous gardez de l'espace pour cette activité dite "shopping" au rez-de-chaussée.
Ils n'ont pas encore appris cela à Monterey.
Si vous allez au coin à droite de l'intersection principale juste en face du centre de conférence
vous verrez une intersection avec quatre murs à chaque virage.
C'est vraiment incroyable.
de toutes façons, c'est ainsi qiue l'on compose et assemble un immeuble commercial de centre ville,
et voici ce qui s'est passé lorsqu'à Glenn Falls, New York,
lorsqu'on a essayé de recommencer, qu'est-ce qui manquait? hein?
Alors, la première chose qu'ils font c'est d'ériger un commerce en surélévation par rapport au sol pour se donner du cachet.
OK. Cela détruit complètement la relation entre le commerce et le trottoir.
où l'on trouve les piétons théoriques. (Rires)
Bien sûr, ils n'y vont jamais, tant que ces conditions existent.
Ensuite, parce que la relation entre les commerces est détruite,
on y rajoute une rampe d'accès pour personnes handicappées,
et ensuite pour se sentir mieux, on y plaque un pansement de nature.
Et voilà le travail.
J'appelle cela les "pansements de nature" parce qu'il existe une croyance en Amérique
selon laquelle le remède à l'urbanisme mutilé est la nature.
Mais en réalité, le remède pour l'urbanisme blessé et mutilé n'est autre qu'un bon urbanisme, des constructions de qualité.
Pas simplement des plate-bandes, ni une parodie des montagnes de la Sierra Nevada.
Vous voyez, cela ne suffit pas.
Nous devons réaliser des constructions de qualité.
Les arbres de la rue n'ont en réalité que quatre tâches à accomplir.
Définir spatialement la zone piétonne,
protéger les piétons des véhicules circulant dans la rue,
ombrager le trottoir,
et adoucir la dureté des immeubles
et au mieux, créer un plafond -- une voûte -- au dessus de la rue,
Et c'est tout. Voici les quatre tâches que doivent accomplir les arbres.
Ils ne sont pas sensés être une parodie des North Woods.
Il ne s'agit pas de créer un décor de film pour "Le dernier des Mohicans".
Vous voyez, l'un des problèmes du fiasco des banlieues est la destruction de notre compréhension
de la distinction entre la campagne et la ville, entre l'urbain et le rural.
Ce n'est pas de la même chose.
Et nous n'allons pas remédier aux problèmes de l'urbanisme en traînant la campagne dans les villes,
Beaucoup d'entre nous essayons de faire ça souvent.
Ici, vous voyez, à une petite échelle -- le vaisseau central a atterri,
R2-D2 et C-3PO sont descendus à terre pour tester le sol
pour voir s'ils peuvent habiter cette planète (Rires)
Ceci vient du fait que l'Amérique est traumatisée par la ville industrielle
si bien que nous avons développé une aversion immense pour le concept de ville,
la vie urbaine, et tout ce qui va avec.
Et donc on peut observer dès le milieu du 19ème siècle,
l'idée selon laquelle nous devons désormais disposer d'un antidote à la ville industrielle,
c'est à dire la vie à la campagne pour tout le monde.
Et ceci voit le jour initialement sous la forme de banlieues ferroviaires
La villa de campagne le long de la ligne ferroviaire,
ce qui permet aux gens de bénéficier des avantages de la ville,
mais de retourner à la campagne tous les soirs.
Et croyez-moi, il n'y avait pas de Wal-Marts ni de petits commerces dans ces endroits à l'époque.
Il s'agit donc réellement d'un mode de vie rural.
Mais voilà ce qui arrive bien sûr, les choses ont changé sur une période de 80 ans
et tout cela se transforme en quelque chose d'assez insidieux
Cela devient une parodie de la maison de campagne, une parodie de la campagne.
C'est là que réside l'agonie indiscible de la banlieue,
et une des raisons qui explique pourquoi elle se prête au ridicule.
Parce que, cela va faire un demi-siècle qu'elle n'a pas répondu à ses promesses.
Et voici typiquement le type de résidences que l'on y trouve, vous voyez.
En gros, une maison sans rien de part et d'autre,
car cette maison nous dit avec emphase,
"Je suis une petite maison dans les bois. Il n'y a rien autour de moi.
Je n'ai pas d'yeux sur mes côtés. Je ne vois rien."
Alors voici cette dernière façade,
une façade, qui est réellement une parodie d'une façade.
Parce que -- remarquez ici le porche.
A moins que les gens qui vivent ici soient des lilliputiens, personne ne va s'en servir.
Il s'agit en fait d'un show télévisé 24h/24h, 7j/7j intitulé "Nous sommes normaux!"
Nous sommes normaux, nous sommes normaux, nous sommes normaux, nous sommes normaux, nous sommes normaux.
S'il vous plaît respectez-nous, nous sommes normaux, nous sommes normaux, nous sommes normaux.
Mais on sait bien ce qui se passe dans ces maisons.
On sait qu'ici, le petit Skippy charge son Uzi,
et se pépare pour sa colle. (Rires)
Vous savez, Heather, sa soeur, 14 ans,
se prostitue ici pour financer son addiction.
Parce que ces endroits, ces habitats
induisent beaucoup d'anxiété et de dépression chez les enfants,
et ils n'ont pas beaucoup d'expérience avec la prise de médicaments
Alors ils prennent le premier qui passe, et souvent.
Ceci n'est pas suffisant pour les Américains.
Voici les écoles où nous les envoyons:
Le collège Hannibal Lecter, Las Vegas, Nevada
C'est une vraie école !
Vous voyez, ils doivent penser que si vous laisser les internés sortir,
ils kidnapperaient un motard sur la route et lui dévoreraient le foie.
Alors tous les efforts sont faits pour les garder à l'intérieur du bâtiment.
Remarquez que la nature est présente. (Rires)
Nous allons devoir changer ce comportement qu'on le veuille ou non.
Nous entrons dans une époque de changement dans le monde, et certainement en Amérique.
-- une période marquée par la fin de l'ère du pétrole pas cher.
qui va tout complètement changer.
Chris m'a demandé de ne pas être trop long là-dessus, et je serai bref.
Sauf pour dire qu'il n'y aura pas une économie basée sur l'hydrogène.
Oubliez cela. Cela n'arrivera pas.
Nous allons devoir faire autre chose.
Nous allons devoir réduire, réévaluer et reconfigurer
presque tout ce que nous faisons dans ce pays et nous ne commencerons jamais assez tôt.
Nous devrons (Applaudissements) -- vivre plus près de là où nous travaillons.
Nous devrons vivre plus près les uns des autres.
Nous devrons cultiver nos produits alimentaires plus près de là ou nous habitons.
L'ère de la salade César à 5000 km est bientôt révolue.
Nous allons devoir -- nous disposons d'un réseau ferroviaire dont les Bulgares auraient honte !
Nous devons faire mieux !
Et nous aurions dû commencer avant-avant-hier.
Nous avons la chance que de nouveaux urbanistes soient arrivés il y a 10 ans,
pour récupérer toute cette information jetée à la poubelle
par la génération de nos parents après la seconde guerre mondiale.
Parce que nous allons en avoir besoin si nous voulons reconstruire nos villes.
Nous allons devoir reconstituer cet ensemble de méthodologies, principes et savoir-faire
afin de réapprendre à composer des lieux dotés de sens -- des lieux intégrés.
Qui permettent -- qui soient des organismes vivants dans la mesure où ils contiennent les organes de notre vie civique,
et de la communauté, déployés sous une forme intégrée.
De sorte que, les lieux de résidence aient un sens
en relation avec les lieux de commerce, de culture et de gouvernance.
Nous allons devoir réapprendre ce que signifie la construction de toutes ces choses.
La rue. Le pâté de maisons. Comment composer un espace public qui soit à la fois grand et petit?
La cour. La place publique.
Et comment mettre en valeur cet immobilier.
Nous voyons quelques idées initiales à ce sujet.
pour refourbir certaines des constructions catastrophiques qui existent en Amérique.
Les centres commerciaux morts. Qu'allons nous en faire?
Eh bien, en fait, la plupart sont irrécupérables.
Ils ne seront pas réhabilités.
Ce seront les chantiers de récupération du futur.
Certains par contre seront arrangés.
Et nous allons les arranger en rétablissant la rue et les pâtés de maisons,
et en retournant au pâté de maisons comme unité de développement incrémental.
Et si nous sommes chanceux, cela ravivera les centres villes et les quartiers
dans nos villes et communautés urbaines actuelles.
Au passage, nos villes sont situées là où elles sont, et ont grandi là
parce qu'elles occupent tous les sites importants.
Et la plupart d'entre elles seront toujours là,
même si leur échelle risque de diminuer.
Nous avons du pain sur la planche.
Nous ne serons pas secourus par l'hyper-voiture; ni par les énergies alternatives.
Aucune quantité, aucune combinaison d'énergies alternatives
ne pourra nous permettre de continuer à fonctionner de cette façon.
Nous allons devoir tout faire très différemment.
Et l'Amérique n'est pas prête.
Nous avançons vers l'avenir comme des somnanbules.
Nous ne sommes pas prêts pour ce qui va nous arriver.
Alors je vous exhorte à faire ce que vous pouvez.
La vie au milieu du 21ème siècle consistera à vivre localement.
Soyez prêts à être de bons voisins.
Soyez prêts à vous trouver des vocations qui soient utiles
à vos voisins et à vos concitoyens.
Une dernière chose -- Cela fait plusieurs années que ceci me dérange,
mais je pense que c'est particulièrement important pour ce public.
S'il vous plaît, s'il vous plaît, cessez de vous considérer comme des "consommateurs". OK?
Un consommateur est différent d'un citoyen.
Les consommateurs n'ont pas d'obligations, de responsabilités ou de devoirs
envers leurs semblables.
Et tant que vous utiliserez le terme "consommateur" dans le débat public,
vous dégraderez la qualité de la discussion.
Et nous continuerons à ne rien comprendre
alors que nous entrons dans un futur difficile.
Alors merci beaucoup
Merci de faire tout ce que vous pouvez pour enrichir ce pays de lieux dotés de sens et de signification,
et d'en faire une nation qui vaut la peine d'être défendue.(Applaudissements)